i'll throw it back at
the writer i said let me ask you a
question
where do you see this playing like where
is this going to be shown
and they said i don't know
i'm like that's a problem
and it's obvious because what you wrote
can be shown anywhere
courtney you have a quote on your
website that reads it's not how many
ideas you have it's how many you make
happen
yeah
i heard that a long time ago it was a um
i was a kid
it was a financial
[Music]
it was a company it was a quote from a
financial company
and i swear i was probably maybe 13 when
i heard that i'm like
that's true
because a lot of folks have ideas but
they don't do anything about them i have
a lot of friends
who you know ah i wish i could write i'm
like just go right
like there's
a lot of content on youtube
you can go to film courage and go like
you know learn how to write you can
learn the process of how to do that and
so that's been a mantra of mine it's
like it's i'm not going to sit down i
don't i never want to be the person that
that says you know you know i'm like 70
years old
oh i wish i could have done this i wish
i could have done that it's like no just
go do it
go do it and so yeah it's not how many
ideas you have
we all have a lot of ideas it's how many
you make happen
and so that is something that i i use to
push me and
you know you do what you got to do to
kind of push yourself and i know who i
am
i'm a competitive guy i need uh you know
those kind of quotes to kind of push me
sometimes because sometimes it is
difficult to sit down and write and look
at a at a computer and write something
and so i know what i need to kind of
push me through and that's the kind of
quote that that helps me push through
and get the projects that i want to get
done done
it sounds like when you have a goal
though there's nothing stopping you i
mean i i think back to the story you
told me earlier that you know you're
taking the bus to sometimes two buses
places you you going to this audition
you don't know that it's michael jackson
and then you get it that was your goal
to to work with him
since you were a teenager
um that once you get that seed that it's
not it's not going to be where it's
going to be a coulda woulda shoulda
you're gonna really do it yeah and i
think that's a really good point and and
i think that's the reason why i quit my
job my nine to five it's like i did not
want to have
i should have or i could have done this
you know because i know that okay if oh
whatever the situation is
you know if i do this so let's let's go
back to to 2016. i just know
2015.
and i decided i want to go
to college to learn how to write how to
direct
let's say i i go to the schooling in
i'm done i have my short film and i
don't get a manager
okay
so now with you know a year two years
three years in
yeah maybe i would have again because in
between that time period i was writing
and then look and sending my resume out
to maybe get back a nine to five job
because money was getting tight
i probably would have gone back to that
that situation there
but
i would not feel bad because
i tried
you know
i never want to get to the point where i
don't try
and then regret that i'm always going to
try
and then if i fail after the trying then
that's different
but to not try at all
i think that's that's a travesty and i
think that's what a lot of people that
you know when they grow older and they
they sit down and they talk about i
should have talked to that girl or i
mean i have those moments like oh this
one girl that was just cute i've never
talked to her but then you find out that
she liked you it's like ah man i should
have said something yeah i don't wanna
go through that i wanna i wanna say okay
i tried i may not have succeeded but at
least i tried
i know right now we're in this sort of
term of the great resignation and and
people are quitting their jobs to start
their own business or whatever and it'll
be interesting to see in like three to
four years
how many people
stuck with that and and not everybody
can do that and that's that's the sad
part not everybody has family that will
help them out monetarily or a place to
stay and
i can see how that would frustrate a lot
of people and i've read comments one guy
said like he regrets doing that and then
he got stuck being a temp in a certain
industry and he never got out of that i
thought that was interesting because
yeah it is a scary leap especially when
you're a little bit older oh my god it's
it's terrifying
it is terrifying like if i was to sit
here and tell you that everything worked
out the way i wanted it to work out i'd
be lying to you it was terrifying and
like i said i i know i've submitted at
least 15 to 20 resumes out there for
jobs while i was trying to hopefully you
know break break into the into the
system in regards to making and
directing projects
yeah it's terrifying um
you're right it's it's
it's a situation now where people are at
a point where they're they are taking
some chances with their careers
and they're not necessarily settling
for what they would have settled in the
past and yeah some people are going to
get hurt because of that um
it's it's a tough one you know it's not
for everybody
but i mean they have to kind of search
themselves and figure out
are they going to be happy with not
trying
or be happy with trying and failing
and
i'm i'm okay with the latter i'm okay
with trying and failing um i've tried
things and i failed at them um i've
tried some businesses that i failed at
them uh you always learn
but
the one cool thing about this industry
is that it doesn't care if you have a
degree
it cares
it cares if you
are bringing something to them that they
can sell
and so
going back to what you were saying
earlier regarding you know i want to do
the christmas movie my way
that's fine
but you're not bringing something to me
that i want to that that i can sell
you know i am the customer
the customer is always right
give me what i want and i'll pay you for
it and that's how i look at it i look at
what's out there right now
what
are networks looking for
and then i write
to that
in a way that allows me to use my
creative you know juices
but i write
to what they're looking for
and that's kind of the way i do it
and i know off camera we had talked
about what i call women in peril and
then you said now it's women in power
and that was news to me i hadn't heard
that so thank you for for letting me
know that but um so they're also looking
for stories like that where where
you know someone's escaping
an ex-boyfriend or whatever
and and and then things again it in the
end it's always a good resolution yes
okay yeah
so speaking of those women in peril
women in power
uh which uh somebody you know uh told me
that that's what it's called now so i'll
use that now
um
movies
lifetime was built on that
there's networks that are built on that
marvista entertainment
is christmas
and thrillers
that's how they make their money in fact
they just got bought out by fox
um
and so
uh we'll see what the mandate's gonna be
on a go forward basis but there used to
be christmas and thrillers that's what
made mar vista entertainment you know
and it it it's a company valued at 100
million dollars
on those pretty much on those two genres
so
yeah you know again what do they want so
yes if you were to make either a
thriller with a female lead
that you know
again watch the thrillers on lifetime
and do something like that but put a
little spin on it you'll sell those
or a chris movie you'll sell those
that's what they want that's you know
that's what you're gonna go for now you
know things like hbo max you know or abc
nbc you know those are different
situations and it's a whole different
ballgame with that like those you're
going to need to have a manager or an
agent pushing for your for your project
at that point and those you know
those are a lot of those are lottery
tickets you know to be able to to sell
your your tv show your tv series to one
of those places um
i you know i still write you know for
those uh in the sense of i haven't sold
one yet
but i am writing projects that are
specifically for those areas and i think
that's another thing to think about is
before you write anything to ask
yourself where is this going to sell a
lot of writers don't think about that
business wise to think about oh i'm a
writer let me just write no no baby um
go ahead and figure out where you want
to send this who's going to look at it
where will it play
and everything is not a netflix thing
you know um you know the
yes netflix has a lot of content and
they need a lot more content but you
know
unless you have an in already at netflix
you
it won't sell to netflix so
you know um
write
when you write something think about
where you want it to sell
and that will help you in reference to
how you write something as well
that's great advice and even with the
christmas and the women in peril slash
women in power movies you still have to
have someone walk you in oh yeah yeah
you can't just you know mail it in cold
so yeah and i would say the same thing
with you know if you want to go to
netflix like i do want to go to netflix
like i have a a social thriller that's a
you know that's um it's like the shining
meets uh the skeleton key you know and
it's a it's a really
fun script um i would love for that to
go to netflix because i want to be the
director of that and and and i know that
they give you a little more leeway
creatively as a director when you take
projects to them
how i'm going to get that into netflix
is probably going to be by looking at
other
similar types of genres that are on
netflix and then getting in contact with
those producers to say hey look i got
something for you guys
so i'm gonna use you know uh i like to
try to walk the talk and if i say that
that's you know what a person should do
i'm gonna try to do the same you know uh
techniques to track down a good producer
to walk something in
right so when when i sit down with an
idea think about if i really am serious
about this where will this sell yes oh
god yeah otherwise what what are you
writing it for
you know it's like
it's
it seems like
yeah i don't know i i i don't understand
why you would write something if you
don't think about where it's going to
sell
i mean you can write something hoping
that it sells but then the question is
where
you know you got to think thing like
that and i think that helps dictate how
how
how you write something
when you know where it's going to go
where you would like for it to go now it
may not sell there but if you if you if
you at least are writing with that
mandate already in your mind you're
already ahead of the game
because sometimes people will just write
something and it's just like okay
so i have a production company and
for a while i was looking at scripts
because i was hoping to leverage my
relationships to take these scripts
other places to hopefully get them made
and with me attached as a director and
so um
i had some people send me some christmas
scripts um
and
it was very interesting because i was
like okay who who was the audience for
this
you know
the idea was interesting but i'm like
okay
you know who was this for
and so i so i would i'll throw it back
at
the writer i said let me ask you a
question
where do you see this playing like where
is this going to be shown
and they said i don't know i'm like
that's a problem
and it's obvious because what you wrote
can be shown anywhere
and that's an issue and i'm sorry that
you spent you know so much time writing
120 pages
but
um
this won't play anywhere
so then i'm giving them advice regarding
you know
look at look at
look at who buys these these projects in
bulk
look at what type of situation it is uh
look at the
story the narrative the characters the
arcs and
you know
go back and write something that's more
like that
and usually i've never had one person go
back and actually rewrite something that
was more like that and then resend it
back to me now i don't want to do any
more christmas movies i'm out of that
business now but i'm saying back at the
time when i was you know interested
in in producing and directing those
yeah a lot of folks don't think about
where it's going to play
so an art film some kind of like
beautiful sort of mumble core piece
is there really a network i can sell
that to
you tell me
what i'm not sure what's it
you know i i don't know except for the
sundance channel or you know which would
be great that's fine that sounds
wonderful that's fantastic okay so if if
i know that's my audience which is sort
of other filmmakers right there
here's your audience so please go make
it just but don't expect to make it
thinking that it's going to get anywhere
else you know anywhere else maybe maybe
ifc maybe
but
yeah you're not going to there's not a
big a big audience there so
you know i like to write for something
that i know is has maybe four or five
different locations where it can land
it's already hard enough to sell
anything why would you want to you know
shoot yourself in the foot
by limiting the place that you know that
it can go sure and then do your research
find out what were their top
um films and and and
watch them and dissect them watch them
with the sound off
you know the whole all that all the
above okay and that will make again we
forget about the business piece of this
they need butts in the seat they need
eyeballs to look at this stuff and so
we want to make sure that we're giving
them what they want because they already
have millions of people that are
watching their stuff
but you know what made uh squid games
huge
was
it was unique
it was different
and you know they got it on netflix
through you know through the south korea
situation but you know you can go back
to bird box
unique stories
you know
um
with interesting twists
so there's a world where that can exist
on a netflix because that that doesn't
play anywhere else
you know netflix is bird box you know um
netflix is is is squid games it doesn't
play anywhere else so
you know yes it is this
but
those those those producers at that
level they already have the in
into these you know into netflix about
somebody already have the you know over
there and so if you're able to you know
convince a a producer that already has
it in
and you have the next whatever that is
really catchy cool
you know um
pro uh product then great have at it but
like you said earlier if it's gonna be
something that's like very art house
mobile core it's gonna be it's gonna be
tough
do you think the blair witch project
would have sold today if there weren't
all these found footage i realized there
were different
incarnations of it that followed but
would would that have been too edgy to
sell to a network today
are we going with the mindset that that
all these other found footages do not
exist or they couldn't exist the the the
all the other found footages have not
followed have not trailed it yet yeah
yeah i think i think it would have it
would have found a home someplace still
okay
because again it's different
different yeah i think so
so you can write something different
original i guess i get now that it's
already been done but yeah yeah but i i
think the point i'm trying to make is
that it's gonna it's
feel free to write something different
and original
it's still going to be difficult to sell
as opposed to you know i know i need 70
christmas movies
it's going to be easier to sell a
christmas movie it's going to be harder
to sell you you may you may sell the
next blair witch project or whatever the
situation is uh the conjuring whatever
but you know and even the condragus you
know you can look at that i mean the
beats are similar to a lot of other uh a
lot of other movies as well it was just
the execution was was pretty cool um
yeah it's
you can sell your stuff but it's just
gonna be harder that's all
for sure yeah
what if i say i want to write the next
tree of life
ooh
and and so i don't want to do um
a women in peril movie or power do it i
see i say write whatever you want but
just understand that it may be difficult
to sell because
it's so specific it's so
not commercial
that's all i'm trying to say is is just
understand that there's a commercial
piece
then there's an art piece
and sometimes the two don't always
coincide and so
there's there's fewer buyers for this
please write it make it amazing make it
brilliant
it may sell it just may not sell
immediately you know